[Music]
on sons of anarchy you played
transgendered Venus Van Dam we have a
picture here and I got a first of all I
would think walking around in high heels
how do you I mean I've tried it a lot in
the privacy of my own home yeah yeah
it's an erotic thriller do it's hard to
pull off how did you pull it off well I
you know oddly enough we were actually
doing Django and in New Orleans and and
I you know I got this call from Kurt
Sutter who is the the writer to show and
uh and he said we play this really yes
oh my god I've always wanted to do that
and so I just immediately I got some
high heels now cuz you can get anything
in New Orleans I mean anything right New
Orleans and and I just with a full beard
and Billy crash mode with Quentin during
the day at nighttime I just I just got
him and I and I walked around and it was
great I actually got pretty good at at
it and then I saw a cobblestone street
and I thought oh well here you go watch
this if I can you know I'll really know
how to walk in high heels if I can walk
down a cobblestone street and I did and
I fell but I was okay and and and I was
able to do it over the three seasons
that we did Gina's you know it was
interesting you make an attractive woman
I will say you you I think you would
agree thank you I appreciate that you
you are did you find yourself would you
look at yourself and think hey as a
woman I actually love quite attractive
well you know this uh Paris Berkeley is
was the executive producer on sons of
anarchy and he said so what was it like
to walk around and and be Venus Van
Damme and I said well I just walked
around really warning to myself all day
honestly now I have never looked that
good up until you know 70 millimeter
you